joined now by general lord richard
dannett who was former chief of the
general staff of course hello timothy
thank you for joining us on the
programme this morning um your take on
what's happening in ukraine at the
moment
well as all news reports are are telling
we are seeing the russians slowly making
advance particularly in luhans province
and uh several donets um they seem to
have got control of a fair part of that
town but what we're seeing as alex
crawford's film has just shown is the
russians reliance on long-range
artillery to wear down the ukrainian
defenders
and attack them at arm's length
this is the tactic that we've seen in
the past it's a tactic from the russians
point of view that is effective uh they
have got a large preponderance of
artillery and they can strike the
ukrainian defenders
at long range and therefore protect
their own soldiers which is why
uh their stated intention of getting
control of the two provinces in donbass
is is slowly coming about despite the
continuing fierce resistance and
determination of the ukrainian defenders
we're speaking to um tobias elwood who i
know that you know well yesterday he
said russia is winning and that the uk
needs to do much more to help ukraine do
you agree with him
well i'm nervous about using the winning
and losing language but i know what uh
tobias means
as far as the russians are concerned
they're restated objective which is to
control donetsk in luhan's province
is slowly coming about
the
interesting thing if interesting is the
right word
is to wonder and to know what they will
do next
i think many observers agree
that the effort that the russians are
making to get those two provinces is
costing them dearly in terms of manpower
munitions and equipment and they may
well have expended
their military effort if they do achieve
those objectives for getting luhans and
donets and i think and many other
observers think that this is the point
of which the war will then go
effectively into the deep freeze as
we've discussed k on on previous
occasions and the russians have now got
that land corridor from crimea through
donbass into russia they failed around
kiev we know that but their more limited
objective of controlling the donbass i
think is within their reach the question
is what will president zielinski do then
yeah and what he would expect the west
to do does all of the uh territory that
has been claimed by russia need to be
seeded back to ukraine in order for the
war to end is a big question i suppose
my lord
well it is a big question but i think
realistically um one has to ask um
what is going to happen because um all
the international statements in the
world
can put pressure on russia to withdraw
to where they were on the 24th of
february and to give up the land that
they've captured in in the donbass
region but but why would they withdraw
uh they will not withdraw voluntarily
nato and a coalition of western
countries is not going to mount a major
attack to throw them out so this is why
many observers i'm afraid i include
myself in that believe that there will
come a point when the russians are
exhausted the ukrainians are still
defending um
outside the donbass and that the
russians have gained control of a
proportion of ukrainian territory and
that is the point where negotiations are
really going to have to start and it may
be the unpalatable truth that president
zielinski will have to accept
that yes ukraine is a certain size but
10 to 15 of it is now occupied by the
russians and that as i say may be where
this war goes into the deep freeze
um the war in ukraine nearing 100 days i
think it's day 97
today do you see any hope of a ceasefire
anytime soon
well it's it's it's going to continue
much the same as we've seen over the
last two or three weeks uh the russians
i think now realize that they were over
ambitious in their initial three-pronged
attack from the north from the south and
pushing uh into the donbass that was too
ambitious there was too much of that so
they've concentrated purely on the
operation now in the donbass which
the big battalions invariably win albeit
win slowly
and as i've already been suggesting they
will get controlled in my view of pretty
much all of donetsk and luhan's
provinces and and this is where the war
in terms of a war of movement will grind
to a halt and as you saw in alex
crawford's film the sort of territory
the ukrainians are now defending uh is
difficult to defend open country rolling
country this is where the big tank
battles of the second world war took
place and this is where the ukrainians
are now are short of armor they're short
of long-range artillery themselves and
if the west really wants to continue to
help the ukrainians this is what has got
to be poured in to shore up their
defenses to make sure that the russians
really feel it's just too much
it's just too difficult for them to push
on beyond the donbass into ukraine into
uk more properly
okay um it's always fascinating to speak
to you my lord thank you very much
indeed for joining us on the program
this morning thanks a lot